one thing about me is them originally
from Libya specifically the city of
Benghazi which usually gets a standing
ovation thank you
I've lived in the States for four five
years now and I think I need to speak to
a manager yeah what's your return policy
because the product looks nothing like
the image I even read the reviews before
moving here you know and I was like wow
50 stars sounds amazing
yeah that's great I was moved to a new
place I have a new roommate his name is
Gian I don't know if you guys are
familiar with the name Guillen or not I
haven't heard it myself so I asked me to
go Gyan oh what a cool name what does
that mean and he said Oh Gyan Gyan is an
Italian name that translates to god is
great oh cool what a flex okay but I
felt kind of jealous because I know if I
ever have a kid I can't name him god is
great in Arabic
yeah cuz that won't fly like like that
and literally won't fly anywhere the
other day I got into this uber and the
driver did this thing where he wanted to
match the name he sees on the screen
with how I pronounced my name so ask me
oh how do you pronounce this I was like
oh it's Muhannad and he was like huh
you know actually here in the states is
pronounced Mohammed like oh cool okay
well that's a great point is just not
how names work yeah they don't change
based on location you know because if
your name is miles and you travel and
you go to France no one is gonna come to
you and be like moon actually here it's
pronounced kilometres yeah
it stays the same
we live in a sad times right now because
I don't know if you know this I've saw
news the other day but in the year of
2018 only over 700 people were shot by
the police here in the US now do you
know how many people were shot by the
police in Libya which is a third world
country in 2018 no one absolutely zero
now some people will argue that's
because Libya has no police which is
true but it's beside the point
yeah it is less the police and more like
where the pole speaking of boy bands I
hate them I don't like them ethic they
suck sorry
I'll tell you the three boy bands that I
hate starting by the ones I hate the
most
so it's the state Jonas Brothers one
direction and Isis yeah I don't like
their work any Isis fans here okay I
don't like them I never some of you are
like hey buddy I think one of these
groups is so different from the two
others yeah I know I'm not stupid
One Direction was now America's mistake
thank you very smart any and here's the
thing if you think if you think you hate
Isis imagine being that group al Qaeda
yeah remember those yeah they used to be
big on YouTube yeah only the 90s kids
can relate I get it
good because I'm kind that's probably
somewhere now in a cave just watching
Isis just thrive on TV and do their
thing and they're there just being like
a stupid Millennials their fancy cameras
just ruining everything
anyway money's Mohandas shaky that's my
time everyone thank you so much
[Applause]